[Musique]
donnez une scène aux artistes locaux
pour la bonne cause ce dimanche à
rambouillet une vingtaine de musiciens à
jouer bénévolement au deuxième concert
guitare et solidarité organise des
manifestations pour collecter des fonds
qui sont reversées à des actions
caritatives de rambouillet des environs
sud-yvelines ça peut être l'aide aux
personnes âgées aux personnes
handicapées ou malades
mais ça va jusqu'en afrique on est d'une
association qui a son siège à
rambouillet mais qui fait des puits
d'eau potable au cameroun sur scène
amateurs et confirmés se sont côtoyés
quatre heures de concert autour d'un
seul instrument la guitare comme marie
platel passionnés de musique folk
[Musique]
je l'en mal
alors j'ai dit je chante à toutes les
occasions et mais surtout les occasions
caritatives et surtout même humanitaire
donc j'avais vraiment la musique au
service de la bonne cause la musique
c'est quelque chose complètement
universel donc par la musique on peut
faire passer un tas de messages
c'est un peu mon but de quoi l'amitié la
solidarité
toutes les valeurs humaines surtout les
expériences de la vie bonne ou mauvaise
cette année le lion's club a récolté
près de 2300 euros
une 3e édition du concert caritatif est
déjà en préparation
[Musique]
ouais